high school graduations hold special
meaning this year after all the
challenges students face during the
pandemic
but for one family in south carolina
this graduation
is especially powerful after the loss
they suffered
during one of our nation's darkest
moments six years ago today
mark strassman has their story
twin themes stood out at dreer high
school's graduation ceremony
hardship and perseverance the pinkney
family
sitting proudly in the stands knows all
about both
eliana pinckney their 17-year-old senior
wrote a message on top of her cap it was
a quote from princess and the frog that
said i remember daddy told me fairy
tales can come true
and what do you mean by that my dad has
always encouraged my dreams since i was
really little he wasn't in the stadium
but did you
feel him there definitely he's always
watching over me no matter what i do
clemente pinckney was her
larger-than-life father
a south carolina state senator and
senior pastor
at charleston's mother emanuel amy
church
one of nine people massacred six years
ago
today a racist gunman rampaged through a
wednesday night bible study
eliana was 11. what was it like
to have him one day and then not have
him the next obviously
the younger you are the harder it is to
kind of understand that these are things
that happen in real life
we are here today to remember a man of
god
president obama delivered pastor
pinckney's eulogy
5500 people heard him find grace
in the unthinkable
the obama's comforted jennifer pinckney
and her daughters eliana
and milana when president obama hugged
you
yeah did it help it did it was the
moment that i realized that my dad was
so much more than just my dad
it inspired me to make sure that i kept
doing what he would have done if he was
here
did she ever a star dancer at drear high
her senior class president the
homecoming queen
she and her best friend addie lee
founded get woke
the group encouraged students and
faculty to work against
racism i'm constantly thinking okay what
do i need to do to make sure that
some other little black girl doesn't
have to celebrate another father's day
without her father
she is truly her father she looks more
like me
but she acts like her dad what do you
see
of him in her she
wants to be involved she wants change
eliana
yvette pinckney
eliana had her diploma but she didn't
get to this moment by herself
[Music]
this family is a profile in resilience
i know i know he's smiling down he's
proud
what do you miss most about him just his
personality but also just being able
to look out in the audience on days like
today and have both of my parents be
there
this fall eliana is headed to temple
university
but this is a challenging week the loss
of her dad
six years ago today and sunday is
father's day
his voice is still inside of my head
saying this is right this is wrong
your tribute to him one you keep on
living
and two you become the person that he
would want you to be
yeah most definitely congratulations
thank you so much in that lyric about
fairy tales from the princess and the
frog
the next line is you've got to make him
happy it all depends on you
her father would approve for cbs this
morning
mark strossman columbia south carolina
eliana is certainly as eloquent as her
father who was a very
eloquent speaker and temple is a lucky
school
yeah they are what a painful situation
but but what an impressive young lady
that story gave me chills and then to
see her be senior class president
homecoming queen oh her
father must be looking down proud